merci à nos six invités on passe tout de
suite à une nouvelle circonscription on
part dans le haut-jura 2e
circonscription les invités de
haute-saône s'en vont les invités du
jura arrive on va parler de la deuxième
circonscription du jura celle de
saint-claude champagnole le haut jura
donc la députée sortante vous le voyez
est membre du parti
les républicains il s'agit de marie
christine dalloz élu depuis 2007
auparavant c'était jean charest au point
le député de cette circonscription
circonscriptions à droite donc mais une
circonscription qui au premier tour de
la présidentielle comme quasiment
partout en franche comté c'est marine le
pen qui est arrivé en tête devant
emmanuel macron et françois fillon vous
voyez les résultats suivent et jean luc
mélenchon nicolas dupont aignan et
benoît hamon david vous nous présenter
nos six nouveaux candidats autour de la
table sur ce plateau on retrouve marie
christine dalloz c'est la députée
sortante de cette circonscription
jurassienne elle à l'investiture
les républicains elle est candidate pour
un troisième mandat elle est également
conseillère départementale dont le jura
en face d'elle nous retrouvons natalie
dessay n'y la candidate du front
national
elle est actuellement conseillère
régionale de bourgogne franche comté et
c'est sa première candidature sur ce
plateau également est candidate pour
devenir député de cette circonscription
du jura 5 euros de champagnole on
retrouve julie lançons la candidate de
la france
insoumise la france insoumise donc
représenté avec jude ils en sont
sébastien mignotte et est également sur
le plateau est candidat pour le poste de
député jurassien alors sébastien
mignotte et le suppléant de christophe
masson candidat europe ecologie les
verts sébastien me notait qui se
présente avec l'étiquette du parti
communiste avec nous également anne
prost grosjean pour le parti la
république en marche
anne prost grosjean qui n'a aucun mandat
mais qui avait déjà été candidate pour
le modem aux dernières régionales
et puis avec nous enfin jean-louis
millet candidat divers droite maire de
saint claude et
conseiller départemental jean louis
millet candidat divers droite
six candidats sur notre plateau mais ils
sont un peu plus à se présenter à cette
élection également candidat francisque
bailly cochet sans étiquette divers
gauche dominique bilde chez du mei et
frédéric jahier upr larbi laabid du pe j
jean daniel maire divers gauche isabelle
marshall lutte ouvrière et dominique
oudin sans étiquette
marie christine dalloz on commence avec
vous vous êtes la députée sortante vous
êtes candidate un troisième mandat sur
cette circonscription
ça colle pas vraiment avec ce que veut
emmanuel macron un renouvellement de la
vie politique
tout dépend ce qu'on entend par
renouvellement de la vie politique
si vous des personnes sans expérience
effectivement mais je constate que dans
les candidats en général dans marché des
gens plutôt expérimentés qui ont fait
d'autres mandats ou certains qui ont
déjà fait des mandats plusieurs mandats
consécutifs en tant que parlementaire
donc je crois que il ya l'affichage et
puis il ya la réalité
et puis j'ai pour moi mon expérience sur
le terrain je suis une élue de proximité
une élue de terrain
j'ai mon expérience mon assiduité qui
est reconnu à l'assemblée nationale ma
présence et ma disponibilité totale pour
ce mandat vous êtes à contre-courant
parce que quand même annuel mac ronde il
faut changer les têtes changent et les
visages vous vous dites je mets en avant
mon expérience je pense que l'expérience
vous savez gérer un pays faire partie
d'une majorité qui peut avoir un
gouvernement dans sa majorité
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut imaginer
concrètement ce qu'est le fonctionnement
de l'institution de l'assemblée
nationale c'est comment on élabore une
loi comment s'applique une loi et puis
concrètement qu'est ce que ça représente
et je pense qu'on ne peut pas avoir 577
députés qui sont issus de nulle part qui
n'ont aucune expérience qui n'ont aucune
vision de ce que représente mandat
parlementaire si vous êtes réélu marie
christine dalloz quel député
serez vous la droite est en complète
recomposition il ya des ministres l air
au gouvernement vous serez une députée
d'opposition
la majorité vous savez vous parler
aujourd'hui la droite est en
décomposition
on a rejoint position enfin on a une
recomposition mais il ya trois seulement
ministre ait l'air kinés ont remis les
leurs aujourd'hui le premier ministre et
de ministre mais je voudrais juste
rappeler que ce sont des aventures
personnelles qui a aujourd'hui de
l'opportunisme politique mais que je
reste toujours fidèle et constante et
loyal aux républicains et à lui dit
puisque je suis aujourd'hui en fin je
travaille pour une majorité qui
s'appelle majorité pour la france
nathalie desseigne vous êtes donc
conseiller régional front national
marine le pen on l'a vu était en tête au
premier tour dans votre circonscription
elle est venue pendant la campagne à
clairvaux-les-lacs vous entendez surf et
j'imagine sur cette dynamique mais pour
faire quoi à l'assemblée nationale là
pour représenter déjà le programme de
marine
pour cela on va avoir une majorité de
députés à l'assemblée nationale
ça vous en être certaine quand on voit
qu'on a eu 11 millions de voix ou au
deuxième tour oui j'en suis certaine
louis et que ça veut dire que vous
pensez qu'ils auraient également trois
députés front national dans le jura
j'espère nathalie des 5 vous êtes deux
sur ce plateau à avoir soutenu marine le
pen au moins pour le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle est ce que la candidature
de jean-louis millet vous embête
non du tout non aucunement on pense le
tour de table
allez on va continuer avec la candidate
de la république en marche
anne prost grosjean vous avez entendu ce
qu'a dit marie-christine dalo en
d'autres termes le renouvellement c'est
bien mais pas succès pas sur cette
circonscription la le président emmanuel
macron vient d'être élu avec un
programme qui a remporté un large
consensus
il a su rassembler les français de tous
horizons qu'ils soient de gauche ou
qu'ils soient de droite sur ses
propositions concrètes qui visent à
moderniser la france et apporter un
renouveau dans notre pays
un renouveau politique également puisque
l'ensemble des candidats qu'il a choisi
non jamais
exercer un mandat auparavant pour la
plupart d'entre eux ce sont des
compétences nouvelles et j'entends par
mes compétences permettra aux jurassiens
de faire valoir leurs dossiers auprès
des plus hautes instances et après avoir
écouté analysé sur le terrain et
apporter mes compétences je pense leur
apporter mon aide pour pouvoir
promouvoir sur jouera que j'aime et que
je veux représente vous retrouvez vous
revendiquez le renouvellement
alors certes vous n'avez jamais été élu
mais vous avez été plusieurs fois
candidate aux municipales à dole aux
régionales si vous n'êtes pas eu
totalement une novice en politique
non je mon engagement politique je
dirais qu'ils datent de 1974 de
l'élection de giscard d'estaing ou mon
ami le maire de mort et jean louis
christ un billet m'avait donné le virus
du centre et depuis cette époque je suis
resté profondément centristes puisque ce
sont les valeurs du centre que j' ai
conservé que je représente également
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que si vous
êtes à la république en marche vous êtes
plutôt tendance centre-droit gt gt udf
et puis udi
et c'est tout naturellement que j'ai
rejoint le mouvement des manuels macron
on reste à droite
du coup jean louis millet conseiller
général maire de saint claud de vous
avez un parcours à la droite de la
droite on va dire vous avez appartenu au
mouvement de philippe de villiers
vous avez appelé à voter marine le pen à
eau avant le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle pourquoi ne pas avoir
soutenu dans cette élection la candidate
du front national
je suis un homme indépendant et libre
c'est ce qui gêne beaucoup de monde
d'ailleurs lui j'appellerai à voter
marine le pen au deuxième tour pour la
problématique de l'hôpital de
saint-claude
parce que j'ai eu simplement la démarche
cartésienne d'écrire à tous les
candidats à la présidentielle
trois mots répondu dont les deux
finalistes alors ça tombait bien l'une
marine le pen a dit qu'elle s'engageait
à maintenir les hôpitaux de proximité et
emmanuel macron lui veut accélérer la
dynamique des regroupements hospitaliers
c'est-à-dire accélérer la disparition de
notre hôpital
alors quand on veut défendre l'hôpital
et bien revenir à la problématique de
l'hôpital elle parlait fort notamment
donc pour moi mais vous m'avez pas
confiance à la députée à la candidate du
front national pour porter ces problèmes
du coup vous faites confiance à marine
le pen à la présidentielle mais pas
nathalie des signaux légiste n'a
strictement rien à voir mais je suis
quand même excusez moi mais oui bien si
vous le voulez mais je veux dire qu'il
ya des thématiques nationales aussi au
front national moi je me suis je me suis
positionné par rapport une problématique
territoriale 1 pour elle c'est tout on
enchaîne avec sébastien avec sébastien
mignotte et le candidat du parti
communiste sébastien mignot t il ya sur
ce plateau une candidate également de la
france insoumise
il n'y a pas moyen de trouver un accord
entre le pc la france est soumise
quel que soit le territoire français a
déjà pour préciser je ne suis pas le
candidat du parti communiste candidat
d'un rassemblement de forces issu de
gauche donc on a donc le ps europe
ecologie les verts dont est issu
christophe masson qu'il candidats
titulaires et donc le parti communiste
on a appelé à un rassemblement à l'issue
du résultat catastrophique qui a eu à
l'issue du premier tour aux
présidentielles
un rassemblement j'ai moi même parce
qu'à un moment j'étais essentielle
titulaire sur la circonscription
j'ai demandé on a demandé avec les
personnes qui m'ont demandé d'être
investie de rencontrer la france
insoumise de rencontrer l'hiver va on a
voulu rencontrer on a voulu rassembler
il ya des questions qui ont été posées
d'autres bons
les questions ne sont pas posées il ya
pas moyen d'avoir d'accord vous sentez
donc plus proche du ps et des verts qui
présente un autre candidat à la
présidentielle que de la france un saut
mise qui présentait le candidat que vous
souhaitiez
après par rapport à la france a soumis j
le parti communiste a soutenu la
candidature de mélenchon après tous les
débats qui a eu il ya des candidats dans
la france qui soutiennent afin qu'ils
soutiennent des candidats français
soumise par exemple à marseille
le parti communiste s'est désisté pour
jean luc mélenchon il ya d'autres
circonscriptions où il ya des
communistes avec la france est soumise
dans le jura on a eu ce problème là on
n'a pas réussi à s'entendre pourtant
j'ai déjà travaillé avec des gens qui
sont un frein sont soumises à des
comices en france insoumise aussi mais
sébastien mignotte et on a l'impression
que c'est plus des accords de partis qui
prime sur la défense de tel ou tel
territoire où la défense d'un projet et
et à chaque circonscription
le pc la france atomise nous en font la
démonstration non sur la question du
projet je vous rejoint pas du tout parce
qu'en 2012 on a oeuvré pour un projet
avec jean luc mélenchon il ce projet est
toujours d'actualité
allez on va donner la parole justement à
jules ils en sont comment c'est possible
que enfin est ce que vous comprenez que
pour les électeurs c'est
incompréhensible que vous partiez
séparées avec le parti communiste
prenez votre micro s'il vous plaît pour
qu'on vous entende bien vous pouvez
rêver de la question pourquoi enfin est
ce que vous comprenez que c'est
incompréhensible pour les électeurs qui
lie à la fois des candidats communistes
des candidats france en suisse vous
souteniez le même candidat à la
présidentielle oui on a soutenu le même
candidat à la présidentielle mais
au-delà de ça on est un mouvement la
france est soumise encore une fois il ya
le petit hic tard à la boutique oh oui
le petit coup du bouquin beh oui parce
que on a un programme qui a été
travaillé collectivement c'est une
démarche collective qui a mis du temps à
être réalisés les gens ont adhéré
plus qu'à une personne mais un programme
c'est aussi une question d'intégrité de
respect des électeurs et nous on croit
l'intelligence des gens de voter pour
quelque chose pour des idées pour des
valeurs donc effectivement c'est dommage
aujourd'hui qu' il n'y a pas eu de
rassemblement possible mais nous on est
clair et au delà de ça enfin moi
candidats de france as with ce qui m'a
plu là dans le mouvement c'est une autre
manière de vivre la politique parce que
là aujourd'hui on entend des fins de ce
que j'ai vécu deux ans rencontrons les
gens ils sont complètement désabusés ils
n'y croient plus
il n'y croit plus à toutes ces choses
les politiques les ongs berné ils ont
l'impression d'avoir été bernée
aujourd'hui avec la france insoumise moi
j'ai retrouvé l'espoir la possibilité de
croire qu'on pouvait faire
et avant les présidentielles sachez qu
on était cinq à soutenir jean luc
mélenchon dans le groupe d'appui après
le deuxième tour
il ya eu trente personnes qui m'ont
demandé qu'est ce qu'ils pouvaient faire
aujourd'hui les gens ont compris
qu'au-delà de voter pour une personne
il pouvait faire et ça c'est
l'opportunité que non vous pouviez finir
votre phrase quand même mais c'est merci
julie lançant merci david on va faire
venir didier fohr de l'est républicain
tout de suite
[Musique]
alors didier vous souhaitiez interroger
nos candidats sion à une thématique qui
a déjà été abordé par jean-louis millet
l'hôpital de saint-claude voilà parce
qu'il ya un dossier qui saute aux yeux
sur cette circonscription évidemment
quand on regarde un petit peu toutes les
problématiques
il ya évidemment aussi la ruralité il ya
aussi la moyenne montagne il ya may à
l'hôpital de saint-claude qui est en
danger
on peut le dire comme ça il ya cinq
services qui vont être fermées alors
vous député je m'adresse aux six vous
député comment vous sauver l'hôpital de
saint-claude peut-être commencer par
madame dalloz oui je veux bien qu'on
n'en sait toujours c'est plutôt comme ça
je j'essuie les plâtres comment on
défendre l'hôpital de saint-claude bien
premièrement dans le projet que porte
majorité pour la france il ya un plan
pour la ruralité c'est le deuxième sujet
sur lequel je veux vraiment insister
parce que la ruralité
on en connaît les atouts les forces mais
il ya énormément de faiblesse et la
principale faiblesse que nous subissons
en territoire rural et je connais bien
le sujet c'est effectivement la
fermeture des services publics
alors les services publics c'est quoi
adressé au public c'est d'abord les
hôpitaux de proximité et c'est aussi les
écoles on a oublié qu'il y avait aussi
une problématique à chaque carte
scolaire avec les écoles en milieu rural
et christine dalo est ce qu'on peut
tenir ce discours et défendre un
candidat à la présidentielle qui voulait
supprimer cinq mille cinq cent mille
pardons emploi puis je vous rappelle
simplement séparé on trafique je
rappelle simplement que le programme a
été modifié à mende et que nous soyons
nous portant un programme collectif
rédigé par l'ensemble aujourd'hui
d'amender la famille des républicains
est de lui dès qu'ils avaient changé
d'avis en éclats en évidence les
législateurs n'est plus à 500 mille
fonctionnaires en moins
on a diminué cette vision là et on peut
porter un programme sur la réduction des
fonctionnaires on a dit qu'il y avait
deux services on ne toucherait pas la
sécurité et les justement les agences
pitallier c2c de ces deux aspects qui
seront sanctuarisés dans le programme
et puis moi j'ai écrit le 4 mars ce que
je suis députée sortante le 4 mars donc
ça fait bientôt trois mois que j'ai
écrit à madame la ministre de la santé
sur le sujet de l'hôpital de
saint-claude pour exiger des réponses à
ce jour
mise à part le fait qu'elle faisait ses
cartons je n'ai pas de réponse
officielle
il faut un plan de mobilisation pour la
ruralité et pour nos hôpitaux de
proximité
on ne peut pas laisser notre population
en danger parce qu on est loin des
grands centres les plus loin des villes
est ce qu'on peut faire tourner la
parole peut-être sur cette question très
précise de l'hôpital de saint cloud
julien manceaux la santé c'est
évidemment une priorité pour la france a
soumises on la veut gratuite public et
accessible
c'est ce qu'on défend on défend aussi
qu'au delà de la santé il ya tout le
bien-être des gens qui vont au tour le
bien-être des gens qui travaillent au
sein de l'hôpital et de l'extérieur nous
on a organisé la une soirée ya pas
longtemps sur la thématique de santé sur
5 l'autre parce que ça nous paraissait
vraiment important parce que là les
conséquences étaient direct sur notre
quotidien
on a fait un atelier des lois autour de
la thématique de la santé
on a vu que les gens étaient force de
proposition avait envie vraiment
s'investir et il n'y a rien de plus
grave enfin gea le comité de soutien a
exprimé qu'on condamne et quand même des
gens à mourir en enlevant l'hôpital de
saint-claude c'est plus que grave on ne
peut pas adhérer à une politique dans ce
sens là pour les 5 services de l'hôpital
et b même un accouchement difficile
monsieur s'il n'est pas traité à temps
c'est le décès ça c est sûr saint claude
la maternité est un service important
j'ai mis au monde mes quatre enfants à
saint claude si on ferme la maternité on
met en danger des gens
sébastien mignotte et oui donc la
question de l'hôpital déjà elle se pose
déjà dans choix politiques dernièrement
les choix politiques c'était des
économies partout au niveau du service
public donc ça veut dire économique de
rentabilité
comment est ce qu'on peut de nos jours
alors que je rappelle quand même à la
sortie de la seconde guerre mondiale
c'est là on a mis en place à sécurité
sociale avec le monde ouvrier avec les
mobilisations sur le terrain avec un
ministre issu du monde ouvrier
faut quand même pas l'oublier donc
comment est ce qu'on peut parler des
services publics qui sont normalement
les services de proximité services de
première nécessité pour les populations
parler de rentabilité la l'hôpital de
saint-claude donc c'est l'oeuvre
l'hôpital limites en à un hôpital par
grande
dans le jura on a un dol a lancé un à
saint-claude là on nous dise un clown ce
qui se profile c'est la fermeture de
saint claude ce que dès le moment qu'on
commence à démanteler des services c'est
tout l'hôpital qui condamnait d'helmand
qu'on commence nathalie des cinq sur
cette problématique de la fermeture de
l'hôpital et de la rentabilité ou non
des services publics donc aujourd'hui on
considère qu'il faut fermer les services
publics non rentable pour nos front
national un service public n'est pas là
pour être rentable mais est là pour être
un service à la personne à la population
donc pour nous c'est un mini vans
inenvisageable de fermer un hôpital
comme saint claude où où il ya quand
même 380 personnes
donc nous dans nos propositions la
première se serait de supprimer la et me
qui représente quand même un milliard
avec un milliard combien d'hôpitaux
pourrions nous sauver l'aide médicale
l'aide médicale d'état ou clandestins
aux étrangers aux étrangers le
donc c'est comme ça que vous financez
auriez loupé une partie des chats un
milliard c'est énorme
parce que là ce qu'on reproche en fait
l'hôpital de saint-claude c'est de
coûter trop cher finalement oui vous
regardez l'hôpital de lons et aussi
déficitaire
pourquoi s'en prendre à saint-claude et
pas lance monsieur maillet est ce que
votre décision subite de vous présenter
la législative vient de la mobilisation
qui a eu lieu très récemment entre trois
et cinq mille manifestants pour sauver
l'hôpital de saint-claude la motivation
elle est que la voix d'homer et peut
écouter celle de parlementaire je peux
croire qu'elle est davantage et nous
avons non seulement l'obligation de
mener ce combat nous avons l'obligation
de le gagner
ça va beaucoup plus loin que ce que l'on
peut imaginer la décision qui est prise
les préconisations de la rs sont
mortifères nous aurons des mortels
agences régionales de santé je précise
le bras armé de l'état entre guillemets
en région pour toutes les problématiques
de santé absolument les couples je suis
désolé mais c'est pour la compréhension
des gens ne sont pas spécialistes qui
nous regardent nous sommes bien d'accord
il faut savoir que on plombe cet hôpital
pour des raisons de rentabilité
à ce moment là pourquoi ne pas fermer
les écoles les collèges et les lycées
c'est pas rentable ça rapporte rien et
ça coûte
si on ne lui obéit à la même logique
comptable l'hôpital de saint-claude
il a un déficit qui est trois fois plus
faible que celui de lons le saunier et
dans ce déficit de 12 millions et demi
cumulé sur plusieurs années vous avez 8
millions 2 c'est-à-dire les deux tiers
ce sont des dettes fiscales
la taxe sur les salaires ce sont des
dettes sociales le vrai déficit de
fonctionnement il ne fait qu'un tiers du
chiffre annoncé alors on a ici on a en
même temps marisol touraine voulait
récupérer veut récupérer voulait plutôt
parlons en un parfait récupérer 10
milliards pour la santé pour les
hôpitaux
et aussi qu'on a des états étrangers qui
ont des dettes de plusieurs milliards
pourquoi nos débiteurs ne pète il pas
déjà d'abord leurs dettes avant
sacrifier nos hôpitaux
jean-louis millet pour la problématique
de l'hôpital où est ce que vous prenez
ou est-ce que vous souhaitez comprennent
de l'argent qu'on récupère de l'argent
pour financer les hôpitaux notamment les
hôpitaux ruraux comme comme celui de
saint claude
ou est-ce qu'on dégage des marges les
moeurs chasse et à la rsr gouvernement
dé dégager savent très bien où il ya des
marges de manoeuvre moi je ne suis pas
parmi les gouvernants de ce pays
aujourd'hui on sait que même par de
bonnes réorganisation nous pouvons
économiser à peu près des deux tiers du
déficit
nous le savons alors plutôt que de dire
on ferme l'hôpital mettons nous autour
d'une table disant quelles sont les
pistes d'économie et il y en a ceci
étant dit on ne peut pas mettre des
patients à plus de deux heures de route
de centres hospitaliers en cas de crise
cardiaque en cas d'avc
en cas d'accouchement difficile on a
chiffré la surmortalité sur la région
saint claude à plus de 80 personnes y
compris des bébés ça ce n'est pas
entendable ce n'est pas acceptable
anne prost grosjean vous représentez
finalement vous êtes la candidate du
gouvernement de donc de ceux qui vont
prendre les décisions dans les mois à
venir pour notamment l'hôpital de
saint-claude quelle est votre position
vous deux candidates la république en
marche sur cette circonscription
vous savez je connais et je comprends la
colère des habitants de saint claude
puisque j'ai moi même été victime de la
réforme de la carte judiciaire il y a
quelques années qui a été exécuté par
madame la ministre dati et dans le cadre
de laquelle le conseil des prud'hommes
de saint claude a notamment été
supprimés ça oblige à une réorganisation
et c'est toujours vraiment très pénible
en ce qui concerne l'hôpital de
saint-claude c'est un dossier qui je
crois est complexe et qui demande à être
analysé
ce qui est scandaleux c'est que les
malades n'ai plus accès à un médecin
nous sommes dans le haut jura dans un
quasi désert médical puisque nous avons
de plus en plus de mal à trouver de
jeunes médecins qui viennent s'installer
dans le haut jura
il ya même dans en ville à champagnole
un cabinet médical qui ne trouve pas de
repreneur et c'est un contexte qui est
difficile mais c'est un constat ça tout
à fait sur ce point emmanuel macron
s'est engagé à doubler le nombre de
centre de médicaux de maisons de santé
mais voilà qu'un pro un projet qui
d'ailleurs a été présenté à vesoul par
françois hollande quand ils étaient plus
souvent la sûreté maison le rallye
devant l'insuffisance de médecin il est
clair qu'en cas d'urgence absolue
les gens sont obligés de se rendre au
service des urgences pour y être soignés
donc je conçois mal qu'on puisse
envisager de supprimer un service des
urgences du ziz urgence car il est à mon
sens est absolument fondamental il y à
d'autres services qui sont menacés à
l'hôpital de saint claud qui sont je
crois la dialyse la maternité et la
chirurgie pourquoi ne pas trouver de
synergies avec oyonnax qui est tout de
même la ville la plus proche
même si elle est dans la m pour réunir
des compétences et pour spécialiser
peut-être certains services soit 5
l'autre soit oyonnax pourquoi ne pas
également avoir un service d'urgence
plus performant notamment par
hélicoptère pour soigner pour acheminer
les malades vers des établissements où
ils seront mieux soigner donc vous
partez sur la rationalisation on est
bien d'accord
madame dalloz peut-être que vous
pourriez répondre à cette question est
est ce que le combat pour le maintien du
service public dans un secteur comme
celui de saint claude est une question
identitaire est ce qu'on défend son
identité comme j'en ai parlé à sion on
défend l'identité d'un territoire et
c'est là où je crois qu'il faut ben moi
je veux qu'on sorte de l'ambiguïté
contre soi on est un con face
aujourd'hui oeuvre de clarté le
l'hôpital de saint-claude ne peut pas
être un alibi
dans le cadre de cette campagne
législative c'est un enjeu fondamental
pour le haut jura s'est pas seulement la
fonction du futur député l'hôpital de
saint-claude il doit se défendre
collectivement et aujourd'hui tous
autant qu'on est ici on doit avoir une
vision claire sur comment on fait
collectivement et pas individuellement
ses portes jeudi sera quand la défense
oui bien sûr d'un député il a aussi des
réseaux au ministère et à paris et je
les connais bien puisque n'oubliez pas
que j'ai occupé cette fonction d'où
l'intérêt mais la réalité c'est qu'il va
falloir qu'on sache se rassembler et pas
en faire une question d'opportunité
personnel je crois que c'est fondamental
merci voilà pour ça les problématiques
merci
didier on va faire revenir david mal
[Musique]
alors david l'exercice est connu
maintenant nos téléspectateurs quel
point souhaitez-vous approfondir avec
nos invités
je vais rebondir immédiatement sur ce
que disait madame diallo il ya une
seconde elle disait il n'est pas
question d'en faire une question
d'opportunité personnel est-ce que c'est
clairement une pierre dans le jardin du
maire de saint claude
c'est une pierre dans le jardin de
personnes l'enjeu de l'hôpital de l'as
de l'avenir de l'hôpital de saint-claude
il est déterminant pour ce territoire on
ne peut pas abandonner et et mettre en
danger l'ensemble de cette population du
massif du haut jura
donc c'est clair on se battra tous pour
maintenir et défendre d'hôpital après
celui qui prend auquel quel que soit
celui qui va prendre la parole qui va
parler plus fort ne peut pas se
revendiquer à lui tout seul le seul
porte étendard de l'hôpital de
saint-claude on a construit ce candidat
ou vizier quand vous disiez ça on
continue david et nathalie desseigne sur
ce sujet précis
vous avez eu une seule réponse c'est
c'est la faute à aimer ça coûte un
milliard par an il faut supprimer la
émeut et on sauvera l'hôpital de
saint-claude c'est ça où j'ai mal
compris
vous avez mal compris c'est une des
solutions il y en a plusieurs et il ya
des moyens de faire des économies c'est
une celle ci est celle qui coûte le plus
cher
il ya d'autres économies à faire donc
concrètement vous êtes député vous
portez la suppression de la m on va
étudier toutes les positions toutes les
1 toutes les idées qui seront pour
sauver l'hôpital ont parlé franchement
pas de langue de bois vous supprimez la
m oui c'est de toute façon oui c'est
dans le programme de marine de supprimer
les on fait quoi avec tous ces malades
étrangers qui qui sont sur notre
territoire
on va déjà penser à nos malades français
qu'on crache je vous propose la question
vous fait quoi des étrangers qui sont
malades et qui réclament des soins pour
l'instant il s'agit de l'hôpital de
saint-claude
voilà donc on va travailler des
étrangers à l'hôpital de simple il ya
une population immigrée assez importante
ou d'origine émigrée
voilà donc qu'on pas forcément la
nationalité française
ces gens ont le droit d'être soigné ou
pas oui tout à fait
oui mais alors 100 m on fait comment on
met un forfait en place ce qui était le
cas du mandat entre 2007 et 2012 pour se
faire soigner les personnes qui étaient
en situation irrégulière ou irrégulière
sur le territoire étrangères eh bien ils
paient un forfait pour accéder aux soins
donc nathalie le saigne ça vous va la
solution proposée par la candidate les
républicains vous êtes en phase on aura
noté sur ce point le maire de saint
claude monsieur millet vous votre
discours sur l'hôpital de saint-claude
est-ce qu'il est uniquement
opportunistes comme le disent d'autres
candidats ici présents non j'ai dix ans
de mandat de maire cette année je crois
que je me bats suffisamment pour
l'ensemble des services à la population
pour ne pas être opportuniste sur le
démontrer sur le terrain et dans les
faits depuis longtemps je dirais que
avec la menace de fermeture des services
hospitaliers de saint claude il ya en
plus ce service médecine de champagnole
et le service médecine de mort et qui
sont dans le collimateur de la rs ça
veut dire que si saint claude ferme
il n'y aura plus aucun centre
hospitalier sur toute la 2e
circonscription et ça c'est absolument
dramatique
alors mme auger simplement je ne suis
pas rassuré ni par les propos du
mouvement en marche parce que le
programme macro prévoit d'élargir les
groupement hospitalier de territoire et
d'accélérer d'accélérer la dynamique de
regroupement des centres hospitaliers ça
veut dire qui va dans le sens d'une
accélération de la fermeture de
l'hôpital de saint-claude
c'est pas vraiment propre à me rassurer
et puis madame déjà entendu ce que dit
madame dalo mais madame dalo en 2007
lorsque champagnole a fermé elle était
déjà député
ce sont ses amis le monsieur sarkozy
était alors président et bien que madame
daloa était député l'hôpital de
champagnole a fermé donc je n'ai que peu
de confiance aujourd'hui dans le
mouvement dans le mouvement les
républicains pour maintenir l'hôpital en
vie anne prost grosjean vous est la
candidate la république en marche
monsieur miled dit je ne suis pas
rassurée par les propositions des
manuels macron sur cet hôpital mais sur
les autres propositions
j'ai écouté ce que vous avez dit en gros
pour le sauver il ya l'hélico et le
rapprochement avec un hôpital dans l'ain
à oyonnax c'est bien ça tout à fait
il faut trouver des solutions pour que
l'hôpital de saint-claude puisse être
maintenu dans la plupart de ses services
et que celui ci ne soit pas supprimer
purement et simplement vous déplier me
recadrer un hélicoptère quel que soit
quelles que soient nos divergences
politiques
il est bien évident que je soutiendrai
monsieur le maire de saint claude dans
son action je prendrai contact avec lui
que nous chercherons les meilleurs
arguments pour sauver tous les services
qu'ils avaient opposé à une logique
centraliser une logique de la rs et il
opposerait à votre propre majorité si
vous êtes n'y a pas de logique qu'ils
soient préétabli emmanuel macron disait
à des salariés d'une entreprise ya pas
très longtemps qui devaient être
supprimés
donnez moi les arguments qui me
permettront de sauver votre entreprise
et je vous promets que je les
examinerait et bien je dirais la même
chose pour l'hôpital de saint-claude
j'irai voir monsieur le maire de saint
claud nous chercherons les arguments qui
nous paraissent les meilleurs pour
maintenir le maximum de services et
j'irai moi-même porter ministre les bons
arguments
madame buzyn vous n'avez pas les bons
arguments tellement jeune et je n'ai pas
un dossier qui soit complet sur les
services qui sont menacés dans l'hôpital
de saint-claude
je dois rencontrer le comité de soutien
de l'hôpital je l'espère en début de
semaine et nous verrons pour construire
le plus rapidement dossier possible un
dossier sébastien mignonneries juste
juste une réponse rapide aux
hélicoptères ra bolide les hélicoptères
ne peuvent décoller statistiquement que
sans vraie jours par an à cause des
conditions météo
donc il faut être malade le bonjour si
on veut être hospitalisé en urgence à
lons le saunier où a lieu sébastien
mignotte sébastien mignotte et vous avez
entendu cette ce discours entre la
candidate du front national nathalie
desseigne et la candidate les
républicains marie christine dalloz
je vous ai vu sourire pourquoi sir est
le problème qui se pose pour la tout
simplement parce que là la france en
immigration je vous rappelle jouons pas
de l'immigration de l'immigration qui
vient sur le sol français mais à toute
l'immigration qui quitte le sol français
va dire tous les jours je parle
notamment des frontaliers on a une
immigration dans un sens on immigration
dans l'autre alors ça voudrait dire que
les frontaliers pour un bon nombre vont
se faire soigner en suisse
maintenant donc ça veut dire que ceux
qui viennent en dehors de france audrey
pas qu'il se fasse soigner en france
motion je comprends pas la logique de
l'immigration ont la france s'est
construite avec l'immigration elle
l'adse combattu halal a battu brest
s'est battu en guerre avec de
l'immigration que je vois pas mais pour
revenir sur le pitaya quand même des
choses makine choc on parle de déficit
ici mais il ya d'autres choses qui
parleront pas de déficit mais jamais sur
la table c'est tout l'impôt que les gens
payent et qui sont reversés aux
entreprises sans résultat mais au
d'aucune on parle du séisme donc c'est
l'impôt compile of un crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi
il s'élève à 41 milliards cette année se
dire on va donner 41 milliards aux
entreprises en pensant que sans
contrepartie en passant que savoir créer
des emplois là on arrive à l'hôpital on
a besoin d'un certain budget avec avec
des nécessités là l'argent qui peut
avoir une nécessité ce territoire des
outils on le met là dedans on arrête de
faire des cadeaux aux entreprises sans
contrepartie
un dernier mot avec vous julie lanceront
sur sur les échanges qui ont pu avoir
lieu qu est ce que vous vous mettez en
place vous retenez sur sur tout ce qui
s'est dit là sur l'hôpital saint claude
de toute façon on est claire là dessus
on défendre certes services publics une
santé accessible gratuité par accessible
accessible nous par exemple on l'a
travaillé dans les ateliers de santé
qu'on a proposé aux citoyens comment
c'était possible puisque encore c'est
aussi une fois une histoire de moyens de
quoi on nous on pense qu'il faut
absolument que l'état y sont relatifs en
demandant par exemple aux médecins de
paix de payer les études aux médecins et
qu'en contrepartie nous donne trois ans
dans les milieux ruraux et pour nous
c'est évident que on est contre aussi
toutes ces fusions départemental
régional qui éloigne les réalités des
quotidiens avec les décisions politiques
ça par exemple
d'ailleurs on voit bien la candidate en
marche et pas au clair par rapport au ca
parce qu'au niveau de sa politique l eau
claire mais quand on parle de l'hôpital
de saint claude où je vais aller
chercher quelques arguments qui vont se
reconnecter un moment donné je pense que
les responsabilités il faut les
relocaliser allez on a passé 16 heures
on a un peu débordé sur ce débat et puis
le précédent je vais vous demander h
haquin 40 secondes de conclusion
adressez vous aux électeurs de cette 2e
circonscription du jura et trouver les
arguments pour les convaincre de voter
pour vous le 11 juin
jean louis billon commencé avec vous
votre conclusion conclusion on va
quitter la problèmatique de l'hôpital a
déjà bien parlé moi je vois que après
ces élections nous avons nous assisté
aujourd'hui entendu parlé tout à l'heure
de recomposition de la droite j'insiste
plutôt à une décomposition de la droite
et nous ce que je souhaite moi c'est
voir se refonder une vraie droite de
conviction avec un éventail extrêmement
large
aujourd'hui le constat c'est que 11
millions d'électeurs ont voté pour le
front national 16 millions n'ont pas
voté ou ont voté blanc ou nul ça veut
dire 27 millions d'électeurs qui ont
tourné le dos aux partis traditionnels
il est temps qu'on se pose la vraie
question que se demande pourquoi ces
gens là se désintéressent de la
politique alors à l'annonce oui
rapidement lui rapidement
donc par rapport à la nouvelle élection
la dynamique macro existe-t-elle je n'en
sais rien nous ce que je souhaite c'est
une opposition constructive une
opposition en attendant peut-être d'être
que la droite redeviennent majoritaires
mais avec des mesures intelligentes et
au maximum cieux milliers
anne prost grosjean la république en
marche votre conclusion oui au niveau de
la politique nationale il est clair qu
emmanuel macron a été élu pour appliquer
un programme qui est déterminé en tant
que élus du haut jura j'entends lui
apporter mon soutien et votée à
l'assemblée nationale les lois qui
permettront la mise en marche de ce
projet en tant que représentante du haut
jura je voudrais aussi souligner les
singularités de ce territoire qui est
une véritable mosaïque et qui implique
plusieurs problèmes particuliers ou
l'avons vu avec l'hôpital de
saint-claude
il y a également des intérêts qui sont
particuliers ce sont ceux des
frontaliers puisque dans les communes du
haut jura nous avons 50 % de la
population qui travaille en suisse
il y à d'autres problématiques qui sont
connues puisque les domaines forestiers
apporte quand même la plupart des
ressources des communes et la filière
bois quelque chose d'extrêmement
important chez merci avoue sébastien
mignotte et alors le problème qui se
pose pour nous c'est la représentation
de la société civile donc faire entrer à
l'assemblée nationale des représentants
directs du monde du travail c'est
important
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à faire
voter des mesures en faveur des salariés
et non plus comme on a connu depuis de
nombreuses années des attaques au monde
du travail notamment avec la loi comrie
qui a connu des mobilisations
dernièrement donc nous l'objectif c'est
l'abrogation des lois de conneries c'est
faire rentrer la société civile dans
toute sa diversité au niveau national
pour pouvoir faire avancer les choses
julie lançons bennoo la france a
soumises on a peur de cette politique
d'austérité
par exemple à sur le territoire
jurassien on voit bien la souffrance des
travailleurs dans les usines
moi ya dix ans les gens ils étaient
épanouis aujourd'hui il ya des bornes
hommes ils sont dépressifs
ils ont peur de se faire licencier nous
on propose de l'optimist on est la force
contre pouvoir qui va pouvoir aller
contre cette austérité et au delà de le
penser on propose aux gens de le faire
donc on est 25 aujourd'hui dans les
groupes d'appui
vous êtes tous invités à venir
participer aux ateliers des lois pour
construire ensemble l'avenir en commun
et le faire parce que bientôt avec la
france un souvenir
les jours heureux nathalie desseigne
alors pour moi avec le programme des
manuels macro on est dans la continuité
de ce qu'on subit depuis 30 ans donc
notre but c'est d'avoir le maximum de
députés à l'assemblée pour faire face et
s'opposer à son programme et à son
système
allez-y continuer oui
non vous ne souhaitez pas continuer
voilà pour la conclusion de nathalie de
sigma et christine dalo 40 secondes
oui alors pour une réelle alternance
mais une réelle alternance
je veux porter à l'assemblée nationale
au nom des juristes et aux jurassiennes
et des eaux jurassien
quatre sujets premièrement l'emploi
parce que on n'a pas parlé mais le
chômage est au vrai un vrai une
disqualification de notre société
donc l'emploi deuxième sujet la ruralité
parce qu'effectivement nos hôpitaux de
proximité doivent être maintenus
champagnole morez saint claude
et puis surtout nos écoles de proximité
nos écoles rurales nos écoles de
montagne
troisième sujet c'est bien sûr la
sécurité de tous les français sur tout
le territoire et le quatrième sujet
c'est la fiscalité
parce que le choc fiscal que nous avons
subi ces cinq dernières années a impacté
le pouvoir d'achat toutes ces raisons je
serai j'en appelle au rassemblement pour
le haut-jura naturellement merci à vous
je rappelle que dans cette 2e
circonscription du jura il ya d'autres
candidats voici la liste francisque
bailly-cochet divers gauche dominique
biche les mei frédéric jahier upr larbi
laabid du pe gigean daniel maire divers
gauche isabelle marche à lutte ouvrière
dominique ou d'un sans étiquette merci à
tous ces quatre débats qui ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui à la gare d'eau vous pouvez
les revoir sur les sites internet de
l'est républicain de france bleu et de
france 3 la semaine prochaine on
recommence à nouveau quatre débats
dimanche avec notamment les deux du
territoire de belfort
la première la deuxième de haute-saône
pardon est la cinquième du doubs on ira
dans le haut doubs merci david merci
j'ai indiqué qui est juste derrière pour
l'est républicain très bonne fin de
journée à tous
bonne journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]